à dharamsala beaucoup d'exilés ne sont
que des enfants qui ont traversé
l'himalaya à pied en voyageant
clandestins souvent effectué à l'aide
d'un passeur
l'obs 1 n'avait que 5 ans lorsqu'il a
effectué ce voyage nous garderons son
anonymat afin d'éviter des représailles
contre ses parents restés au tibet la
nuit
je rêve souvent de ma maison au tibet je
veux retourner dans mon pays
pour revoir mes parents
une séparation douloureuse depuis 2012
le jeune garçon âgé de 13 ans vit dans
le pensionnat de sept écoles tibétaines
il fait partie de ces derniers arrivants
mon père et ma mère ils m'ont envoyé
pour que je puisse étudier notre culture
tibétaine
c'est un pendentif qui célèbre les 80
ans du des lamas